dude let me ask you a question okay what
would you put in a 50-year time capsule
all of the doo-doo that's in my [__]
right now
yeah they yeah they love that joke yeah
the boys next door the boys next door
[Laughter]
that's how I sound when I [__] bust a
nut
oh shit's all over your back
now that's like The Sopranos
that's what they do when they bust a nut
okay oh
you know yep that's like the one sound
they always make
I've never watched a single episode
really I'm sorry
um what would you put in it
50-year time okay 50 year Time Capsule
to open 50 years from now to roll a
decks of tributes
give each other three genuine
compliments
yeah okay
I want you you're sexy I want to be I
don't know
they're they're gonna they're gonna want
no because they're gonna want this for
real
who the fan fiction people okay they
might be 25 now but they're you know 19
years old at heart and I know that right
now they're feeling their
their work
come to life okay I see come off it um
come on
so we're gonna do this yeah you're bad
as [__] okay thanks dude so are you
that's all I got sorry
back at you bro ditto
um
call the most famous person in your
phone that would answer
Obama's tough to get a hold of who's the
most famous person probably
I don't know probably me what oh I mean
it's probably post Malone
let's be real that number stopped
working yeah
that is true
um or Emma
I feel like she's just as famous as
postie yeah but no no post Malone's like
a global laundry yeah Emma's not doing a
[__] Arena yeah that's true doing 100
sure you [__]
yeah is that where they were rain that's
nuts yeah
that's crazy I think Emma could you know
shut down like a little Speakeasy and
Bahrain yeah yeah but postie can walk
through Bahrain and it's like oh yeah
yeah
it's nuts um Obama shares phone number
to find out how much are planning to
vote I didn't even know he did that 80
things yeah I don't even know that he
did that American people I have provided
my phone number
so you can send me pictures of your
beautiful cans
I love to see your cans
that's right
me and Barry we got a phone line
we want to see all your big jugs and
your [__] Supple clitorises oh Jesus
Christ don't Joe calm down Joe
sorry we had that pastrami you know that
makes me horny oh hard as a [__] rock
foreign
I could pave a park with this semen yeah
my tributes are permanent
and more more of a monument than a
tribute
comes out as Stone was the last time you
went to the doctor I don't know but we
just text now
I mean the doc we just send pics now I
don't really go to office anymore
what do you think of my bunner dude
yo doc no monthly check-in
everything's still good with my boner
how's this [__] hanging how's this [__]
what do you think has this grown at all
your erection still looks fine Cody
all right for show how'd you rate this
wood yeah
hey Doc you think I got any STDs
I can't tell just from that picture
Cody your penis is green please come to
the office immediately
laughs
my doctor called me
yesterday
and uh shout out to him by the way he's
a [__] he's awesome
but he was like he's like yeah by the
way I'm moving on from the office and
you know uh so like every hope you know
have a good life basically and I was
like no dude what like
what are you gonna do like I want to
know you're my [__] doctor you know
yeah like what are you gonna do after
and he's like oh I'm thinking about uh
you know I'm gonna try to like get more
part-time work so I have more time to
like
work on you know other stuff maybe some
content and I was like oh Dr Mike type
[__] huh and he was like maybe something
like that how old is this something like
that he's probably like
late 30s oh okay I was like well you
know I'm a YouTuber so if you ever need
like any advice or anything like that
and he's like oh I know yeah sure I
would love that I've seen your dick and
I've seen your videos
it's so crazy someone with a small dick
like you can make videos like that you
know after I saw your little dick and I
saw how big your following was I thought
God anyone can do this wait till I put
my big doctor dick out there and just
take this [__] by storm thanks little
man have a good life
this first video I've seen Cody Ko's
nuts yeah
uh Dr Dave here
um they're this big
that would be so funny that would be so
funny if he click baited
me for his very first video ever
exposing kodako's actual dick size he's
like
he's like it's not very big and he just
pulls his nuts out but this [__] is look
at this I just made me think it's like
had this moment afterwards afterwards
where I was like it's funny that
like I don't know 10 years ago this was
a joke career yeah and now literal
doctors are like
oh my God yeah yeah exactly
we're dead dude doctor's [__] kind of
sucks we're doomed man I'm gonna start
doing something that's you know I don't
know that that's a more serious career
now now we're gonna get only ugly
doctors
yeah all the hot ones are gonna go
become content creators exactly you're
gonna see that dude [__] in the
doctor the whatever that is who the
white coat that they wear yeah you're
gonna see your doc like on Instagram
with that but shirtless underneath yeah
yeah yeah
new video up
laughs I did a [__] yeah whatever
yeah I did a post whatever surgery
uh yo did a triple triple bypass surgery
this afternoon
there's blood all over him all over his
abs oh my God
patient ended up dying I'm so torn up
about it
old lady died on the table today [__]
was [__] up
I pulled out her heart to see it beat
one last time
then I ate it because I wanted her to be
a part of me oh my God that's so funny
they're like [__] boy doctor also like
serious Killer really thinking about
things this morning
just had this old lady dial me today on
the table makes me just think about life
he's just doing the thinker with his
dick out
nah man I just pictured blood all over
his face and he's like you know I run
red lights
oh nice yeah yeah eat it period yeah
yeah I got it got it